because satire is now impossible and
reality has become the only source of
comedy a new bombshell report reveals
that after a full year of the Muller
investigation of Russia collusion it
turns out Muller himself colluded with
Russian oligarchs that it's a true story
you cannot make that up we will analyze
this major conflict of interest for
Robert Muller and his never-ending probe
then speaking of comedy
the legendary stand-up and SNL alum
Dennis Miller stops by to talk comedy in
the age of Trump finally a silver lining
for our vomit of culture I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I like that word vomit --iv that's so
good I'm gonna start using that one
we've got a lot to get to today before
we talk about these things and the
single funniest news story of the last
ever I want to tell you about movement
watches
I love movement watches you've heard me
talk about them before I love them they
help me keep the lights on that's very
nice but more importantly than that they
just make an excellent product so I'm
wearing mine right now I wear the
revolver this watch I get so many
compliments on this watch I really have
never gotten more compliments on a watch
ever it is super cool they have new ones
out now and I if if you need to send me
an early wedding present the one I want
is the Bronze Age revolver so send them
my way they're super super cool movement
has come very far from being crowdfunded
kids working out of a living room in the
past year they've not only introduced a
ton of new watch collections for both
men and women they've also expanded to
sunglasses and fashion-forward bracelets
for her
eyewear movement sweet little elisa
wears movement it is just a really cool
company they've grown like crazy they've
now sold almost two million watches in
over 160 countries they're
revolutionising fashion on the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank
movement watches start at just 95
dollars if you went into a department
store watch like this would cost 300-400
maybe more just 95 dollars
so movement figured at the by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and the retail markup
providing the best possible price to you
classic design quality construction
styled minimalism get 15% off today do
it free shipping free returns and a
really good discount on the watch go to
nvm t-dot-com kofi face COV fe fe MVM
t-dot-com
/ co FFA co v fe fe you've got no
consonants in the first part and then
consonants in the second part I know M
VMT comm / Co FFA CY movement keeps
growing check out their expanding
collection and join the movement you're
not gonna believe this one today the
this news story is so good and I can't
but this is like the perfect punch line
to the entire robert muller russia
collusion investigation it turns out in
2009 special counsel
Robert Muller now investigating
president Trump for colluding with the
Russians himself colluded with the
Russians I know I'm just as shocked as
you are it is an absurd punchline I will
get through this because I want to get
to Dennis as quickly as we can of all of
the arguments to take down the Moller
investigation to stop this
anti-constitutional clearly unamerican
power grab here to overturn a
presidential election of all of the
arguments to take down this
investigation this one is the best
here's what happened see if you can
follow this it kind of seems like a
really weird sad James Bond story but
with but because it's real-life
government and there's a lot of just
inefficiency and poor decisions that
happened along the way so in 2009 robert
muller was running the FBI and the FBI
asked russian oligarch Oleg Deripaska
for some help to help them with an
operation that they were doing even the
name I have to assume that Oleg is short
for oligarch because that is like out of
a cartoon that the Russian oligarchs
name is Oleg Oleg so this is a the FBI
asks Oleg for some help on this
operation I'm gonna call him Gorky I
think that's a that's another good
nickname for him so the FBI asked Gorky
they asked Deripaska to spend millions
of dollars of his own money to fund an
FBI backed operation to rescue a former
FBI agent Robert Levinson who was
captured in Iran while working for the
CIA in 2007 former FBI agent now working
for the CIA abducted in Iran in 2007 now
it's 2009 FBI asks the Russian oligarch
for help Deripaska agreed Deripaska
spent millions of dollars of his own
money he had meetings with the FBI he
had meetings with that disgraced former
FBI agent Andrew McCabe in Paris in
Vienna in Budapest in Hungary in
Washington DC all over the place they
meet there working together very closely
now the operation worked they actually
were able to locate Levinson with video
and photographic evidence they tracked
him down in Iran they were about to go
get him and then Hillary Clinton shut
everything down Hillary Clinton at the
time was the Secretary of State she
got everything down at the last minute
who knows why maybe she didn't want to
deal with the political fallout maybe
she didn't want this mission to imperil
her presidential ambitions who knows
they were on the verge of getting him
millions of dollars had been spent they
had evidence that knew where he was and
then he was gone the operation ended in
2011 Levinson has never been found this
is 11 years now after he was captured
score another failure for Hillary
Clinton so this story by the way which
is a punch line to the Muller
investigation actually is another piece
of evidence for why it's so good that we
did not elect Hillary if she totally
bungled this and appears to have made
certain political calculations that left
this guy stranded in Iran God knows
we're back to Robert Muller so the
Russian oligarch Deripaska turned up in
the Muller investigation Deripaska has
long-standing ties to Paul Manafort the
former Trump campaign chairman a mana
Ford allegedly offered Deripaska private
meetings about the 2016 campaign they
had long-standing financial ties before
this Deripaska sued man afford this past
January because he was alleging fraud in
a 2007 investing deal so now let's bring
in the hookers now Deripaska is former
mistress the Belarusian prostitute
Anastasia vashu kovitch who was
videotaped on a yacht with Deripaska and
the Deputy Prime Minister of Russia
because the oligarchs run the country
it's a very corrupt country this a
Belarusian prostitute is claiming to
have evidence that Deripaska had a plan
to interfere in the 2016 US presidential
election okay so you say where's the
evidence let's bring in the evidence the
only trouble of course and this happens
with Belarusian hookers is that she's
currently stuck in a Thai prison are you
still with me are you still tracking
this because there's a lot going on so
put that aside
speaking of hookers Deripaska is one of
the Russians that the FBI questioned
about the democrat funded hit job
dossier that alleged that donald trump
paid russian hookers to relieve
themselves on a bed that barack obama
once slept on now the FBI after this it
was alleged to have happened the FBI
busted into Deripaska hotel room they
asked him about that crazy dossier in
the democrat funded dossier Deripaska
left at them because he thought they
were kidding because the story is absurd
now okay none of this really matters
much so far there's we've had some
hookers we've got some strange
preferences and bedrooms we've got some
corruption okay fine everybody in the
everybody in the world has a plan to
interfere in the u.s. presidential
election oligarchs frequent a lot of
hookers these are tales as old as time
nothing really special here what matters
here is that robert muller has not
mentioned Deripaska in the mana fort
indictment
despite Darris Vasquez being a central
figure in all of mana Ford's dealings
with Russia so we've got this huge
wide-ranging Russia probe
we've got mana Ford actually being
indicted and yet the central Russian
figure here just doesn't show up on the
indictment that's a little weird we also
know that the United States has recently
instituted sanctions against Arab Aska
the duly elected government this is
coming out of the White House has been
dealing very harshly with Deripaska but
the unelected anti-constitutional
bureaucracy has been playing softball
with him
now why would robert muller play
softball with Deripaska well Muller as
the director of the FBI asked a Russian
oligarch to underwrite an FBI operation
to get around US laws Muller tried to do
something indirectly that he was
explicitly prohibited from doing
directly now okay he's trying to subvert
the law he's trying it okay that that
doesn't look good
but then what really matters is the quid
pro quo here because if you're not
familiar with Russian oligarchs one one
neck characteristic of them is they
don't generally do favors in exchange
for nothing they don't do things out of
the goodness of their heart Russian
oligarchs are not known for the goodness
of their hearts so so the question is
what did Deripaska get or expect in
return for his twenty five million
dollar donation to Mahler's FBI maybe I
don't know does that explain why this
particular Russian oligarch didn't turn
up on Muller's indictments maybe maybe
did Muller I want to avoid the
transparency that is required by law I
don't know let's ask all of the experts
on this of across the political aisle
that's what Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz the same Alan Dershowitz
thinks this was a way to avoid
transparency because he might have
broken the law Mel
nice loan who's who is a former Justice
Department lawyer for Bill Clinton
former Clinton administration lawyer she
wonders if the the first FBI operation
was even legal
because that first FBI operation where
the FBI asked the Russians to fund this
this operation looks like it violated
the anti-deficiency Act which prohibits
the government from accepting voluntary
services and the reason it does that
makes perfect sense because then there's
an obligation there's a debt to be paid
off and it gets really tricky down the
line when you start indicted people for
Russian collusion but you don't indict
the central Russian oligarch GW
constitutional law professor Jonathan
Turley he thinks exactly the same thing
this is not a right-wing conspiracy this
is not all this is not you know Sean
Hannity saying this on his show this is
a Dershowitz Sloan Turley these are all
people who have worked quite publicly
for Democrats but they're very good
lawyers and this is their legal opinion
this is the best ending to all of this
isn't it isn't this the best ending to
all of this because this miss Muller
thing has been going on forever it's
been going on I don't know since that I
think the Coolidge administration at
this point but it either was the FBI
investigation then it was a Muller thing
it's basically the one-year anniversary
of the Muller investigation and now the
punchline is robert muller colluded with
the russians it's what credibility does
he have what credibility does this
investigation now have we know that it's
a probably unconstitutional it seems to
violate the supreme court's rulings and
i think the case was Morrison V Olson
both the opinion and the dissent of the
court we know it's far too expansive but
also it seems that the even that even in
the carrying out of it they're trying to
avoid transparency they're trying to
skirt the law they're trying to cover up
possibly illegal actions that were
undertaken by the head of this
investigation ten years ago nine years
ago doesn't look like there's a lot of
credibility here but keep looking I'm
sure you'll find that Russian collusion
somewhere you might find it really
really close to home you might find it
might might actually be you guys who
were doing it really really wild the
Democrat the Democrats pay collude with
the Russians and pay for this steal
dossier then the FBI seems to be
colluding with the rush
I think Donald Trump is the only guy in
this country who has not colluded with
the Russians Donald Trump may be the
last American who didn't collude with
the Russians unbelievable we got to get
to Dennis Miller before we do that I
want to tell you about a product that
has changed my life I'm talking about
dynatrap the dynatrap indoor fly light
this thing I am not exaggerating when I
say it changed my life
in Southern California we get a lot of
flies and fruit flies you know my
apartment is basically all just empty
wine bottles so you got all these fruit
flies around and you plug this thing in
it caught all of them it just caught
everything things that I didn't even
know we're in the air just caught them
this is such a good product summertime
is officially upon us the only thing
more annoying then well I don't want to
get too political about this but you
just heard my rant I think you get what
you get what I'm alluding to the only
thing more annoying than that is flies
mosquitoes and other insects invading
your home so we would like to thank the
sponsors at dynatrap the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps now they've got one with
four indoors with the indoor at dynatrap
fly light it really works it works
immediately it is so so good
I'm I'm both a client and a customer
this is like the only solution I've
found to endure fly problems that
actually works there is nothing more
embarrassing and gross than hanging up
those that fly paper you know I used to
do that in New York and doesn't look
right when you've got company over and
you so Jay just duck all of the bugs
that are being ornamented from the
ceiling you know it doesn't look good
this looks really good really a sleek
and fashionable go-to dynatrap calm dy
and a TR ap comm enter the promo code
daily wire Dai ly w ir e and receive 15%
off of any of their products get it it
really works done throughout the safe
silent and simple solution to household
insect control ok in the age of Donald
Trump reality is funnier than absolutely
any sketcher stand-up act around
nevertheless we will get to a
professional funny man and one of my
favorite comedians Dennis Miller Dennis
Miller just launched his second weekly
podcast for podcast one it's titled the
Dennis Miller option where he discusses
headlines pop culture
and tries to make sense of an
increasingly nonsensical world here's
Dennis Dennis thank you for being here
nice to be here my friend how's your day
it's going very well that's going pretty
pretty nicely now you have one you I
don't know about you I'm having I guess
wall has two despite our listen soldier
on without Iran right now it's just
really hard do you think sure foot told
me when we were when we were above the
kill zone on Everest just put one foot
in front of each other and keep moving
somehow we'll get through this together
I I hope you know I was so nervous
because Ben Rhodes and Dan Pfeiffer they
assured me that everything was gonna
fall apart without the cooperation of
the worst regime on planet Earth I hope
we can make it I hope we can make it so
long probably not without my daughter
the Betty Mammootty story is when I was
first introduced to lovely bribe in Iran
but somehow well soldier I will truck
along I now I want to talk about another
great foe of the United States Michelle
wolf now you have won multiple Emmy
awards you've won Writers Guild Awards
you've hosted a bunch of TV shows you've
hosted radio podcast the Dennis Miller
option you've also headlined the White
House Correspondents Dinner back in the
bush one years I wanted to know on a
scale of Hiroshima to Nagasaki how badly
did Michelle wolf bomb I don't think she
did in her world right people listen
have to understand it's a completely
it's a schism now between the two sides
I think on her side she was uh I never
know if the word is it feee D faded you
know I think she was probably praised my
only thing was when I read about it and
I got angry because uh I saw Sarah
Sanders sitting I said I'm going to see
a man cry
I said I did not know who it was so I
put up a tweet about researching or in
getting back with a joke on Wednesday
which is when my podcast is and all of a
sudden it was like the it absolutely hit
the fan and I realized that the internet
really is the Wild West you
you put up something that Aradia would
say underwritten all of a sudden you're
like the old lady who goes over the
Horseshoe Falls with trash can and ends
up in the white water turned at the
bottom you're just getting dermabrasion
up and would do for a day or two and
then I realized I guess that's what the
Internet is about and when you were in
the crosshairs of it you should handle
it with a suitable degree of aplomb
because certainly I have people on
Twitter so that's it that's the way it
happens and it happens quickly it seems
like it happens to like well I saw that
tweet when you sent it out and I
immediately got it I got the joke you
know no one knows who this woman is and
you're gonna have to research her and
then you can talk about it on the show
and immediately everyone pounces on you
and they say ha ha you don't have a
quick wit ha ha you know and I couldn't
tell if it was the left being obtuse or
if they genuinely just just didn't get
it
and this this does bring us to it I
think the defining characteristic of the
Trump era which is that the left is
humorless these days and conservatives
during the Obama years conservatives
still had a sense of humor but now the
left seems totally totally humorless why
can't they take a joke right now
oh I don't know I won't you know I will
say this when Obama when Obama won and I
want that speech that first night in
Grant Park that I think that's the party
Chicago and I'm not that much of a
Chicago benefit but then I saw those
upturned faces and people with all that
hope in that and I thought this will be
good for this country
honest to god I remember saying I hope
he does well I'll give him a few months
here see but I don't I don't think we're
like you were laughing that I put that
thing up above I don't think the
Lester's handled Hilary's loss all that
well it's the simple truth that I think
that was such a lock in their head
that's all I can say is it must be it
must have been a kind of livin for them
I remember when i watch the Jacob Javits
Center that first night and it was like
a snowflake Jonestown and I thought my
god I have never in all my years of
having political opinions
you ever come within a Lightyear of
crying over a politician I never I don't
take it like that it's not that
important I you know I was you know
Obama's approach to it was not my
approach but he seemed like a genial
bloke seemed like a good family man I
didn't agree with a lot of it okay I
never hated them I never wanted to cry
that he became president I was just
looking at I go I guess they've got more
vested in it on the secular side because
they seem genuinely you know devastated
I just don't get that devastated so can
I speak and say that there's nobody on
the left is having any fun with it no
dad I just guys are having fun with it
but can I say by and large the the left
was devastated by her loss yeah which is
surprising to me because I think she was
the ideal candidate it's not like Obama
lost their son anything he has charisma
he's a great speaker and like I said he
was of the era you can understand why
that might have everything but Hillary I
mean Jesus say what you will about
Donald Trump but give him this I think
that his outer voice is indeed an
accurate depiction of his inner voice
warts and all well I don't think
Hillary's inner voice and outer voice
I've ever even had a cup of coffee
together and so to keep people crying
about it I thought my god something
something happened here it's bizarre
they human list about it I don't know I
think they're saying get to lick their
wounds a little more but up to this
point I would say that there's a pretty
reeling schism in this country right now
and whenever they the ones who have just
lost get a shot they're gonna take a
shot at you and that's what that's the
way of the world and it was I love that
phrase the snowflake Jonestown that is
when you look down at that scene that
Brooklyn scene when Hillary lost I
remember John Podesta came out because
she didn't show up she was throwing desk
lamps in her hotel room or something and
he comes out and he says thank you for
being here for Hillary she's always been
here for you except for right now the
only time it matters since she's not
here for you they they were devastated
and yeah
that side is more secular the Democrats
booed God at their National Convention a
few years ago so perhaps they've got
some misplaced longings but when I
watched that set of michelle wolf at the
White House Correspondents Dinner
I didn't hear many jokes she told a few
jokes but what I heard a lot of is she
just accused people of being liars that
was like her punchline she said you're a
liar and you lie and you're a
disappointment to women and as though
that were sufficient to qualify as a
joke which I don't think it did how was
the culture of that dinner and politics
and political comedy how radically
different was it back in the early 90s
when you were doing it for George Bush
Senior first of all I would say that
whether you liked her jokes or hated her
just I don't think she did that badly in
the room am I am I missing the point no
you're absolutely right they did those
journalists were laughing yeah when I
listen to clips and when I saw people
cutaways would like they always do
people who laughing well a lot I think
yeah I remember one I missed it didn't I
i'ma still one year and I do remember
that being a bit of a train wreck
president didn't I miss coming it was
actually quiet in the room that's true I
mean they they did give it to Michelle
in the room I sort of felt it was that
distinction of claps not laughs that
they were going along with her because
she was saying things that they
politically agreed with even if she
wasn't reinventing comedy we might all
have selective hearing and maybe I
median and uh listen I'll have to defer
to your expertise yeah I remember
getting some left and I would say this I
was surprised to hear that nobody better
than because when I did it for Bush 41
I'm sorry I was I had to get my wazoo
armor-all
I was no better than so I had the run
joke by the White House Correspondents
people I had to run jokes by the White
House people and then when I was in the
green room I remember first 41 who's
such a mensch
he comes up an exam with bars and I
don't say the f-word I know I mr.
president
crank up an F word in front so it was a
bit of a different thing man listen man
the curtain comes down on the culture
now in the space of a evening
it can happen midway through an evening
in a commercial break the culture can
change back then one is that I even know
when I visited 15 years ago 18 years ago
and I'm not being worried a little bit
well come on it's over fifty five
hundred days the world turns my own
around 15 seconds things go away or they
come back we're living but I assume it
was always like this even in primordial
days I assume this is human behavior
it's just now through social media the
entire world its privy to your synapses
reactions to things are animists our
collective consciousness it all happens
in real time almost all across the
planet I would say the big thing that's
changed this social media do I think
human nature has changed no I think
there'll be a point in in somewhere way
down the line you're even here this
stuff like it's the Outer Limits episode
where David McCallum if you just go and
they can just start talking to each
other with your thoughts and we can tear
each other a new ass I'll never even
open our mouth I think that's what's
coming down the road so I think right
now all the stains is the Animus level
of the consistent throughout history
sister right now we're all privy to each
other's Frank you know well that's and
that's certainly true that the culture
can change on a dime
speaking of cultural changes on social
media I don't know I know you've been on
Twitter a little bit I've been perusing
your Twitter feed the last couple weeks
you might have heard of this fella Kanye
West he's a famous rapper apparently and
he's been tweeting a lot of very
conservative sounding things a very
conservative though he's tweeting out
Scott Adams videos and Thomas Sol quotes
and all these little conservative
YouTube videos do you think that that
reflects any change in the culture no
matter how short that change maybe is or
are the conservatives and the right
finally winning a little bit of the
popular culture with Donald Trump and
Kanye West or am I am i celebrating too
much and reading too much into it
no I think
listen next to war hold in the future
everybody will be famous for 15 minutes
which looking back on I had always taken
him with a bit of a grain of salt
because I'm not a modern artist man and
I always thought he was just the you
know I hang you know at Studio 54 sort
of New York downtown scene guy but when
I look back on that that is so prescient
but I think I should read more about him
because that's a pretty brilliant thing
to say the second was a brilliant thing
I've heard or one a is the Breitbart
saying the politics are downstream from
culture right and I do think this Kanye
West thing listen up to this point in my
life my introduction my only knowledge
of Connolly Kanye West since I'm not a
hip-hop fan is that I remember him being
loaded on stage at an awards ceremony
with Taylor Swift and grabbing a reward
singing that's very boorish behavior
that's my take on him when I see what
he's done in the last couple weeks do i
lionize him is he my new you know I need
fictionally the monolith in 2001 I don't
think that but that's a pretty important
defection on their side mhm I really
think that I think he in the in the
lexicon of the day I think he was tired
of getting played III write the
Democrats are playing African Americans
and I I I think that things are starting
to fall that's really interesting what
he did role has been out there for years
on the front lines of this I don't even
think you know just the fact that Kanye
West is reading Thomas aw but well good
for you brother because I like the
curious mind and Thomas Thals brilliant
absolutely brilliant man who they've
been ignoring for years so it's
something is there some fissure there
yeah no I don't quite understand why I
don't hear as much about it now this is
it strictly on that flash poll they did
where Trump's approval goes from 11 and
the black community to 22% the black
community and as maybe the people on the
left thing we can't keep crucifying
Kanye because that that's not going to
play I just like I like free thinkers I
like people who don't walk in lockstep
and when he stepped that like that I
thought well I now have another
but on Kanye West it's not just grabbing
a trophy off Taylor Swift yeah I said I
should learn a little more about this
because I think what he's done is pretty
brave and I think it's opened up an
amazing tributary of dialogue library
Coulter always said this country's too
afraid to have that conversation
all right well where's Eric Holder
coming forward in the last week or so
say well I guess somebody is not afraid
to have a conversation we found that
yeah well I really think I hope that's
what Holder was referring to the fact
that this guy's not getting much you
know supply train support is a I think
that's very telling I think that's going
to help Kanye's cause more than will
help the liberal cause that is a really
good point and you you know you've been
comedian and a amazing cultural observer
for for such a long time and really one
of my favorites have on this point that
you brought up a little earlier on the
boorishness of the culture or you know
the the f-word that George Bush Senior
he said oh come on I got my wife here
tonight don't go blue or that sort of
thing now it's not just the White House
Correspondents Dinner it's not just
Kanye taking that award from Taylor
Swift you hear it even those Comedy
Central roasts with few exceptions are
so often just a litany of vulgarities
and the most trying to one-up one
another of the most disgusting thing to
say we use a loose language all the time
now is there any hope that the culture
will rebound in a way that gives us back
a little dignity or a little class or
using language in a nicer more elevated
way or do you think for the time being
that might be lost and we've got to
navigate these new waters that we're in
I would be funny if I commented on that
I say the f-bomb all the times my dad's
dry just don't do it on air well except
when I'm when the job description is not
but left to my own devices I find it a
good word in my act like the day my
balls are in my act no I don't think I
am but if I used the the f-bomb yeah I
can't lecture anybody on that but when
I'm in front of a president when I'm on
TV and when I'm in front of a corporate
crowd that doesn't need that
Sturm and Drang in their day is it very
easy for me to not do it of course it is
every time I do a corporate I say to the
guy so who's the guy who signs this
cheque and then I say to him do you want
it PG do you want it pg-13 and you
wanted R and if he says pgic fine
there'll be no swearing in it he wants a
pg-13 I say fine there might be a couple
swear words but I won't use the f-block
I
I just find it easy to ship that stuff
out and like I said is there is there a
new Vulgarian ism in the country I don't
think so
I think this is the way it has always
been in small crotches except our small
class now is the entire world due to
social media I really think that social
media never have lived less lived been
more chronicled the minutiae leonato we
have to invent a word and not a I think
that might be Elizabeth one good use of
the native language this is all the
stream of consciousness for years was
either in our own head in our own living
room with our own friends at a tavern or
a bar or with a group of like-minded
people now everybody knows everything
about everybody and what I say this
social media has allowed us to all come
together as one and probably realize
there was never really any good reason
for that is a devastating but accurate
observation because it's true when I
tweet or I go on Facebook I don't I
don't feel as though I'm addressing a
crowd of thousands I feel like I have a
drink in my hand and I'm spouting off on
what everything crosses my mind that
that is very true might makes you think
twice before you tweet Dennis before I
let you go you have this new podcast
it's very very good the Dennis Miller
option it just launched how's it going
and where can people find it well if
I've done two and the third ones on
tomorrow Dana Carvey is up all right
it's you can download these on iTunes
and I'm just learning the lexicon so I
will spare you hearing me say we drop on
Wednesday like um you know and like your
putting out and do new album week we
appear on Wednesdays and you go to
podcast one I love spring sports one but
we decided to your riddle is because I
found out that Sports is the most you're
gonna get it seems to me unless you're a
big Dan Patrick or something like that
you're probably gonna get $20,000 people
were sending me emails but I'm not
saying they were shoveling them in like
coal into a speeding train car but I
wasn't getting email saying list but I
like Brazil Indy but I don't I don't
like Ford so we're putting it into a
more generic thing called the Dennis
Miller option we're probably going to do
two of those a week the next one's
tomorrow like I said it's an hour with
priori is absolutely the best guest TMR
t-shirt in the history of any sort of
medium and comedy it's my thoughts on
the world
it's my thoughts on policy it's just for
a stream of consciousness for an hour I
was just looking at it on iTunes and I
don't know much about the ratings but it
seems to be okay on there and we'll see
how it goes III think that you pretty
much have to crawl back into this and
say say out loud what you're thinking
and see who shows up for that if it's
enough they keep you on if it isn't they
whack you that's sort of where it's
really really good I I listened to the
first episode right when it came out I
am I got I don't want a fangirl too much
you know but I am a big Dennis Miller
fan myself and have been for years
so you everybody I highly recommend
going out and getting the podcast yeah
absolutely
I'm blood you can't you can't see me
right now but I'm blushing even in my
swear the Italian skin Denis very hard
to talk to you that's something I
probably shouldn't tweet note to self no
Dennis thank you so much for being here
great to talk to you and I can't I'm
looking forward to the podcast with Dana
all right thank you bye bye Dennis
Miller how cool is that guy on Saturday
May 19th Dennis will be performing at
the Riverside Theatre in Milwaukee on
Saturday June 23rd Dennis will be taping
his next stand-up special at the Bijou
Theatre in Knoxville Tennessee Dennis
can also be heard on his other weekly
podcast red circle sports with Dennis
Miller with podcast one
and his twice daily syndicated 60-second
radio feature the Miller minute I want
to get some of those that guys got so
many podcasts okay I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube don't forget
don't forget the conversation is today
it's coming up this is it this is your
last chance to subscribe if you go to
daily wire.com right now you subscribe
you can ask questions during the
conversation that will be coming up for
real soon
5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific only
subscribers can ask the questions
everybody gets to watch but only
subscribers can ask many are called but
few are chosen we thank everybody who is
already a subscriber you help us keep
the lights on it's very nice of you if
you subscribe you get me you get the
under clap ensure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you can't ask questions the
conversation you'd ask questions in the
mailbag which you can go do right now
there it is now we I have been sippin
deep the John Kerry vintage for the last
week the Kanye vintage Kanye caused all
of those to pour in I'd been and those
were delicious
I know I'm saving those now for a
special occasion because now I'm on the
Bob Muller in colluded with the Russians
vintage of oh that's that's a really
sophisticated brew and it is best served
cold because after a year of Democrats
trying to overturn this presidential
election now it looks like they're the
ones who colluded with the Russians mmm
serve it cold nice chilled leftist tears
mmm-hmm go to daily wire calm we'll be
right back to talk about our vomit of
culture
vomit --iv I'm only I'm just covering
this story so that I can say the word
vomit --iv the word of vomit 'iv is
being used to describe Lars von Trier's
new murder movie called the house that
Jack built it's a con film festival here
is the preview for the house that Jack
built the old cathedrals often have
sublime artworks hidden away in the
darkest corners for only God to see the
same goes for murder
[Music]
apparently that's the only eight second
clip of the movie that does not entail
dismembering children so that's all they
could use for the trailer if this movie
just debuted at con and it actually
prompted the moviegoers almost uniformly
to storm out of the theater in disgust
that's true just to point this out
because I should go without saying but
some people aren't familiar with these
festivals it's not that it caused an
audience of your sweet aunt Ethel to
storm out and discussed it cause the
attendees of the confi
to leave and discussed the con film
festival attendees are some of the most
decadent debauched people on the face of
the earth they're all these show
business types their show business
elites how many times has Harvey
Weinstein attended the con Film Festival
one of the attendees this year Kirsten
Stewart took off her shoes on the red
carpet and walked in barefoot
they are debased people they're
debauched people and even they said that
this movie is too much one reviewer said
of the film he said that it is gross
pretentious vomit --iv torturous and
pathetic that's actually the review that
Ben gave of my show but it applies
differently to this movie because of how
gruesome and bloody it is another
reviewer called it a vile movie should
not have been made
actors culpable as if to say the people
who just got the script they just played
their parts they are morally culpable
for how filthy and rotten and demonic
this movie is so what's the movie about
according to Rotten Tomatoes lars von
SIA
his upcoming drama quote follows the
highly intelligent Jack Matt Dillon over
a span of 12 years and introduces the
murders that define Jack's development
as a serial killer we experience the
story from Jack's point of view while he
postulates each murder is an artwork in
itself as the inevitable police
intervention is drawing nearer he takes
greater and greater risks in his attempt
to create the ultimate artwork of
dismembered and children one viewer from
calm
not a reviewer but one of the people who
saw it tweeted out and said seeing
children being shot and killed is not
art or entertainment so this you know
people have been scandalized by artwork
for a very long time this is nothing new
but perhaps this has gone too far
perhaps who knows I haven't seen the
movie yet I've only seen me eight
seconds which still have blood all over
them but apparently they're the safest
to air I think there's a silver lining
here actually for the culture you might
ask what is the silver lining to maiming
and mutilating children the silver
lining I think is that the culture has
turned a corner because you you can keep
going down this path obviously a certain
material would be shocking even 50 years
ago that today would be absurd you know
Ricky and Lucy on I Love Lucy
they didn't sleep in the same bed
they're a married couple and they slept
in separate beds on the show because it
would have been too scandalous to two
out there to show them sleeping in the
same bed they couldn't use the word
pregnant that was a culture back then
now you just name and torture all of
these children on on screen and that
that's pushing a boundary slightly these
things can't go on forever
a grotesque culture will exhaust itself
eventually Jimmy Kimmel actually talked
about this yesterday he said I think
we've had enough of the Trump jokes of
the Trump hate you
have you Jimmy you hate Donald Trump but
they've just gotten to the end what more
is there to do how much further can you
go Kanye West is talking about this he
says you know everyone's just hating
really hard and hating and hating and
mean and mean and hating and hating I'm
gonna love people I'm gonna try
something different I'm gonna do
something that's that's not within the
popular culture Facebook and Twitter are
talking about this even they're offering
a bad solution because their solution is
censorship but they're talking about
this problem of just meanness and
crassness and vulgarity people criticize
Donald Trump for being a little bit
vulgar but they themselves behave in a
much more vulgar way than the president
does maybe you know take a look at the
man in the mirror huh there's so much
meanness there's so much coarseness and
vulgarity Michelle wolf at that White
House correspondent stares so gross it's
so how much further can you go it's like
the experience of reading the marquee
Sode if you ever read at the Marquis de
Sade read a book called 120 days of
sodom and he's where we get sadism from
and sadistic so the Marquis de Sade's
both a pornographer and a philosopher
and you read it you start to read it and
you think ooh this is a little whistle
little titillating Oh yikes should I I
don't
should I be aroused by auteur no this is
and then you get to the end and you're
just so horrified and disgusted with the
material and with yourself it sounds
like this movie you know which is just
people are doing all sorts of depraved
things and it gets a violent vicious and
all of that and by the end you saying ha
gross it's the experience I think of
whenever you really feast the flesh so
whenever you can just let's just use
Thanksgiving as an example you could use
more scintillating examples well let's
use Thanksgiving you go and you say okay
I'm just gonna eat as much as I can all
day so you start out the day you start
eating and drinking and eating pie and
Turkey and right by the end you don't
want to eat anymore you're just so fat
and full and disgusted with yourself
tired and you want to go to bed and do
something else
this is true whenever you feast the
flesh on anything it could be sex it
could be gambling it could be drinking
and carousing whatever whenever you just
get exhausted by the end of it and I
think that's what the culture has done
here with crassness and meanness and
vulgarity that's not to say that we're
gonna have a really nice pristine
culture now I just think we've sort of
reached the end of it in some ways the
the Trump election might mark the end of
that and what comes afterwards I don't
know but you're seeing the culture
slowly starting to move in and if these
debauched depraved showbiz types are
gonna walk out of a movie because it's
too crass and vulgar and violent that
could be a good sign that things are
looking bright among all of the dead
bodies on-screen and the husk of our
culture that things could be getting
better okay make sure to tune in for the
conversation that will be happening in
like three seconds it's gonna be at 2:30
Pacific 5:30 Eastern Time so do that
I'll be with Alicia Krause and me and
ask all of your questions I won't answer
I believe been touted my conversation as
me is staring blankly at the screen and
then quoting in abathur
obscure Catholic theologian that
nobody's heard of that's probably what's
gonna happen so you know tune in and and
I'll just I'll give you this
just straight vist it and then I'll put
some theologian but you gotta tune in to
find out which one
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knoll show I'll see you in like an hour
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you